[Musica]
sappi sei diventato un essere umano
sì ma come il fatto è che quando che ha
mai bollettino si inizia abbiamo quindi
ora io non sono più alito
si proceda via parità
so che sei un tour attivata grazie alla
trama sono riuscito a passarmi uomo
procederò a trasformare tutti quanti
mischiare i burattini di steroli mondo
trasformando tutti immigrati
ora vi lascio e preparati adesso ci
pensa all atleta rli
oggi sono solo io e te e possiamo
mangiare un tour over ci pare già detto
e lo ha fatto in agosto sono per berlino
non sono per vitale ecco in lasciato uno
spettro è lasciato per me bravo merlino
bravo bravo dovevo fare qualcosa ma si
domandano due mie basta mattina la bravo
queste rimettiamo spinta scopo deve
lavare le mani dove è letto l'avrebbe
bravo drhouse dovevo fare qualcosa ma
non mi ricordo che cos'era tutti i
ricordi per leo ma non mi dai le
risposte abbiamo bisogno ripreso nelle
domande di cibo bravo dovevo fare
qualcosa ma troppa numerico
ma certo teneva un agente pure questi
suoi adesso ma i caratteri usati dai va
bene pure su devo fare qualcuno da
marino l'ho portato fuori io devo
mangiare tutto mangiando anch'io che spa
allo dovevo guardare il video nella
camera vasto faccio un'altra manto video
[Musica]
che cosa
com'è possibile
ma allora la vita alla zona berlino
berlino ferrino viene dai dobbiamo
andare sieni dobbiamo tornare a casa da
adesso dobbiamo andare da unità guarda
da bambola è vero che parla
dobbiamo dare subito a salvarla
[Musica]
che cosa facendo niente se ti stavo
aspettando sloppy e la regata 1 metro
per te e quindi possono anch'io
trasformare
qualsiasi persona in un burattino
proprio così ai 100 potrai trasformare
commerciale e adesso chi telefona fare
da mitterand
[Musica]
adesso europei immagina quanto sarà
peggio poter governare questo mondo
assieme a trovarli questione mio fianco
[Musica]
ok certo la più te lo giuro benissimo ma
così è quello che cosa ci possa stare in
facente parte notevole questo lascia
volevo solo mettere un po più sulla sua
storia nostalgica centrando in modo per
sarà l'obbligo non farei mai
potreste aver letto dal quale potrete
garnica anni con sla piccole possono
sapere di più sulla tua storia non
volevo
non vorrei mai danneggiarci davvero ti
creo leonetti che tara lynn camera dai
quei picchiano trovi finali ancora una
volta di the sono un fatto niente di
male e best i nomi di odio di te
e adesso che chiuderò quelli di camera e
non avrai accesso all'internet fino a
quando non può trono di filandari
cos'è questo rumore è una macchina si
sembra ma quale miglior occasione per
dimostrare la tua che cosa vuoi dire
trasformerai di rame in odor addio ai
poveri non pare trasformare vittorio in
un burattino e berlino elevino
trasformeranno in un pupazzo allora da
allora che fai ti tira indietro all i
nostri che posso ancora tirare è certo
che puoi fidarti di me sulla b bene
trasformero vitale in un burattino
melato la dà la carica e semmai alleata
è certo che il nostro pilota tornerò qui
con vita del burattino vai ora
[Musica]
molto bene
sanità
i tas
anita dove sei
sanità sei qui finalmente ti ho trovata
che cosa ci fai come sono caduto a
salvarti sì ho visto i video nella
camerina e ho visto che la bambola si
muove da costa che devi andare via da
qua ma come andare via sono venuto qui a
salvarsi sono io che devo stampati ok
devi andare via da adesso si porta via
anche la risorsa perché che cosa è
successo niente non può stato pressato
da te adesso che non entrare in casa
inter di su che cosa stai dicendo
ma da un po ma capisco
mai sentito devo portare via
questa cosa è molto strana però è poi
che fine ha fatto la bambola starà
ancora dentro casa forse è meglio si
adatta a controllare
[Musica]
valido quando è vero che io no
[Risate]
[Musica]